osteoporosis is not a calcium deficiency
problem so many people have in their
mind that if i have osteoporosis
i need to start drinking a lot of milk
start taking calcium
so they start taking like 500 milligrams
of
calcium carbonate every day expecting
their osteoporosis to
magically go away well there's some very
interesting data
that talks about calcium supplementation
not only not helping you with
osteoporosis
or reducing their fractures from
but increasing the risk for heart
attacks
and even stroke and i'm going to put
some links down below
one study talked about if you took 500
milligrams of calcium every day
it potentially could increase the risk
of heart attacks by 30 percent
and risk of getting a stroke by 20
percent
now in a review from 2018
using the routine use of calcium and
vitamin d
did not reduce the risk of osteoporotic
fractures
but it did increase the risk of kidney
stones
now the thing about calcium is that it's
very very tightly regulated
so if you get too much calcium it
becomes very very toxic
very similar to too much iron or too
much
copper versus other minerals like
magnesium or potassium
you can get a lot of that and your body
will get rid of it
but not calcium too much calcium is very
toxic to your cells
and if you look at certain health
conditions as people get older
they're just filling up with toxic
calcium extra calcium that lodges in
their arteries in the joints
thirty percent of the population in the
u.s has
calcification in the arteries and
there's a really good test
uh that you can take i'll put a link
down below and it's called coronary
artery calcification test so
that's a very very good test to predict
overall mortality
too much calcium could lead to all sorts
of problems there's one condition
i want to make you aware of milk alkali
syndrome
this is a condition where the person is
consuming
too much calcium and it could be from
drinking too much milk or taking an
antacid
here are the side effects kidney failure
death psychosis confusion
dizziness poor appetite and the list
goes on and on and on
so what i recommend is you get your
calcium from your food as much as
possible
and never take calcium carbonate because
your body is a heck of a time absorbing
that osteoporosis
is a severe loss of bone mass
and density and bone is made from
protein
minerals and calcium as well it's not
just calcium
so it's the whole package osteopenia is
a lesser version of that
and then osteomalacia is where the bones
become
soft and in a child it's called rickets
and this is a vitamin d
deficiency what's even more important
than calcium
is your vitamin d level is your stress
level
too much chronic stress or taking
steroids
prednisone for example will destroy the
bones
post menopausal women who go through a
lot of
stress and go through a lot of menopause
with adrenal stress because now the
adrenals have to back up the ovaries
sometimes develop osteoporosis from a
combination
of higher levels of cortisol and lower
levels of estrogen
so that can cause a loss of bone also if
you have digestive issues malabsorption
can create a problem usually because
you're not able to absorb
vitamin d and then you can't absorb
calcium
vitamin d has a purpose of increasing
calcium absorption by
20 times so without vitamin d you would
have to consume 20 times
the quantity of calcium that doesn't
make sense
vitamin k2 is another vitamin that is
ignored this is like
vitally important vitamin k2 has a huge
purpose
of making your bones very very strong
and solid
to keep the calcium in the bone and keep
it out of the arteries and the other
soft tissues so
this right here is probably one of the
most important factors
in dealing with someone with
osteoporosis the other thing that's been
proven is that regular exercise can
greatly reduce the risk of osteoporosis
you want to keep your stress low make
sure you get a lot of sun
or you can take vitamin d3 k2
eat very healthy so you can get the
minerals from the food
i mean one good source of calcium is
leafy greens another source is some
high quality grass-fed organic cheese so
in this video i just wanted to increase
your awareness that
osteoporosis is not just a calcium
deficiency it's much more than that
and i don't recommend taking high doses
of what they normally recommend calcium
carbonate
because of this problem right here which
i'll put some links down below
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it